we are live all right hello everybody
welcome back to another YouTube hang out
super excited to have Jennifer price
with me again the fantasy copywriter
here to help her grow over business Jen
how you doing I'm doing great thank you
it's been a while since the last session
I know it's been a really long time
since our last session I since our last
session I quit my job and started my own
business and there's been a lot that's
happened it's been like what five months
or something I love it so so let's get
into what's been going on how can we
help oh gosh um well I um like I said I
put my job I've been continuing with
some of the advice you gave me to do
some YouTube videos and keep consistent
on Twitter and Facebook as well um one
thing I really has struggled with is
consistent writing a blog posts uh what
you know for a writer is really bad but
you know I wanted to say consistent with
one thing and I really wanted to like
make sure at least one video a week and
many weeks have been way more but I've
done at least i'm pretty sure than one
video a week at least since i think
we've talked so um that's been cool and
um and yeah and i also took a contract
sales position with a company here in
town its sales sells digital advertising
so um that's kind of a good fit for my
business because some of my clients need
digital ads placed to help promote the
landing pages that are right for them
and that's good fit for him because he
often needs landing pages written so but
the challenge for me there has been to
you know kind of co promote both
businesses sort of and then also just
balancing my time you know finding time
to sell for both businesses as well I
was like do my actual writing so so yeah
so that's probably what's been going on
with me so in the line look at my notes
from the last time we met you we're
trying to do one video a week that was
that your personal series that was the
the joblist important role in that was a
personal thing or a book and then one of
our own copywriting right they're going
to do two videos a week one personal one
copywriting what is that evolved to
since we spoke
well it's sort of evolved to I kind of
have five different ones that I've been
doing like a five series so one has been
my fantasy copywriting and then I
continued with the jobless in Portland I
wasn't as consistent with that I've been
more consistent lately with that that I
just I evolved into take the leap
because I come about like um jobless in
Portland wasn't the best name because I
didn't want to stay jobless in Portland
wrecked I mean I wanted that you know
again jobs to my business I was like I
don't want to manifest jobless in
Portland right so I change the name of
that and then I've been doing um uh I've
been doing fantasy Friday's which is a
I've been featuring a fantasy quote or
artist that I think in body is fantasy
and I really enjoyed that a lot like
that's like sort of become almost my
favorite I really enjoyed that but
that's kind of evolved to and then I
I've also done a fantasy review i'm only
them a couple of those where i would be
a product that it fulfills my fantasies
I think it'd be fun to kind of explore
that a little bit more and find products
I don't have that I want but I happiness
ease about you know and talk about that
um and then I'm missing another one
what's my last one I've been doing um oh
and of course my book series my fantasy
fantasy books ito series which I kind of
wanted to evolve into a coffee shop
series and I sort of started that but I
haven't completely finished my what I
want to do is make a website page that
kind of reviews coffee shops in Portland
and talk about my you know book and how
my book is evolving while i'm there at
the coffee shop so it's kind of
fulfilled two purposes there am I
thinking is that people in Portland
would want to know like what are great
coffee shops because as I you know have
you know quit my job I work a lot of
coffee shops which is where i'm at right
now I met one of my favorite coffee
shops so um you know so I'm working a
lot and there are times when I'm like in
between stuff and I'm like I don't know
where to go so I'm thinking myself would
it be right there was a website for
other people like me who like want to
find a quick coffee shop really quick so
that's where that kind of all came from
and so ha what is the schedule look like
you've got the 5-series don't cover
their own yeah I have not been
consistent which is actually kind of
been my goal for this month is to come
up with a schedule I've been doing
obviously fantasy fridays I've been
doing those on fridays and so I've been
pretty consistent about doing those
almost every friday every
why i miss a friday and then I've been
kind of switching it up with another one
um you know it's during the week what
I've been kind of doing is on Mondays
I've been doing a take the leap video
and that's been kind of evolved actually
partly from when you give us our
mastermind challenges I post this up on
Mondays and so I've been doing those as
part as take the lead but those no I'm
thinking those may not always fit take
delete that might fit like one of my
fantasy copywriting videos sometimes so
I might want to evolve that but and I've
been kind of doing my fantasy
copywriting videos on Wednesdays when I
do them so i think i could fit the other
ones in on the other days maybe like on
tuesdays i could do my coffee shop
series and maybe thursday is my fantasy
review series so is the goal to get to
21 a day or are we still doing I think
so yeah I might be some ambitious look
wanna go you want to get to one a day it
might be ambitious though I kind of I
kind of would like to but I'm but maybe
I could just be consistent about women
posting them so when I post zoomy but I
post like famous friday every friday and
a copywriting one on wednesday and then
I feel and the other ones but maybe I
just you know do it on the same day
every chat every week I don't know I'd
like to do it every week every day but
I'm worried about time I am worried
about time yeah it is its I couldn't do
it once a day on my own you know I don't
know how people do it I was doing one a
week maybe two week on my own and then
it wasn't till I had help in terms of an
editor so then ramped up or did one a
day than to a day now three a day but
there's six people who work on my
youtube channel team so it's right not
it's all I have to do is be in front of
the that's a lot easier than all the
stuff that happens behind the scenes um
why I would love to see I agree in the
consistency I'd love to see it's hard
for people to bounce around right like
if you do a take the leap and then
nothing comes up like I subscribe to
your channel because I like to take the
leap video and then I don't see whether
take the leap for three weeks then it
then you're bummed you're playing with
the expectations ready people will
bounce it's going to be harder to get
the audience um I'm I you know I
honestly like at the same time I like to
see you have stopped to help to your
business so people know you're a
copywriter that you're sharing your
wisdom the stuff that I've seen recently
and maybe I'm like blocking stuff out it
seems to be a lot more of the personal
stuff I feel like I haven't seen a
copywriting video in a while yeah that's
me none of you haven't you haven't I did
one like maybe three weeks ago and I
actually spending I filmed one like two
weeks ago and I just have an edited yet
because you're right cuz like it takes
you more time and you think and you like
I have to sit down edit and sometimes I
think okay I love it for half an hour
I'm like oh my god that took me two
hours so yeah it takes a chunk of time
um you know especially you're picky like
me but yeah um I agree i don'ts good to
have standards I you know I would I
would love I am looking back to my notes
from our last session I would love to
see that still I love to see one
copywriting video per week and one
personal video per week as a mix of the
other stuff um if you can do more than
bait but I feel like the copywriting
blends are suffering unless you don't
want to use the channel to grow your
business unless you just want to use it
as a as the branding thing as I'm giving
my advice I'm sharing my experiences you
build up the the gen brand and that
leads to other things you don't want to
give the practical writing knowledge um
I think when we first started though the
idea was here how do i use YouTube to
get me clients and help me grow my
business um yeah I definitely want to
grow my business I totally want to but
you know what's funny is I think what I
do is I tend to hesitate more than I
should on doing the copywriting videos
because they take more time you know
they take more time because I can't just
like I mean I can there have been times
when I just you know got on camera and
talked about the concept but for the
most part if I'm doing you know showing
some copy examples it takes time to you
know to write the copy and then you know
show that on the camera and it's just
six more editing
and more time to actually do the writing
so doing one of them wonder yeah I
wonder if you can make it simpler by not
covering as much yeah cover one small
thing each week so there's ongoing
digestible bite-sized content yeah I
like that idea I actually have the
thought because I've been thinking about
like how to motivate people to sign up
for my for an email from me and I cause
it'd be nice to get start getting emails
because I don't have an email list um
and I have the thoughts of like maybe
smell like a copywriting tip every day
and then I thought I could just do like
a little video tip every day but that's
that's pretty ambitious too but if I did
even if I just did once a week then I
can also post on my youtube channel so
either way they're getting an email or
they're getting on my youtube channel
yeah I mean the little bites you may be
able to pull from a longer session that
you did sometimes they'll take like an
hour long any of you I do with somebody
and then we'll we'll launch and release
uhh just one question so somebody has a
question we'll just answer that question
ok and that becomes its own standalone
video so you can do those little tips
yeah even just this value even in just
uh I'm asking it together so if you have
made a bunch of videos you know you have
this seven step process right for today
never it's a headline set headlines flow
more fussy and you started making videos
like all over the place it wasn't an
order right so you know if I'm
subscriber I'm not gonna know to go back
six months and this is where the
headline is and then this is right so
just mixing that together in one email
to say hey here's my process and here
are links to all the videos to learn
about it that's right right that's your
checklist that people can can save and
then go on watch those videos maybe if
you had bullet points or something for
each one is part of some free download
right like here are the three things
that you need to know from this video
and then just link off to the video yeah
um I mean if you make more videos then
you can keep adding to that list
but I think I think I think if the goal
is to make your business more successful
and to get clients then you have to
start talking about things that are
relevant to clients and not just the
personal ah a lot of people are do the
opposite they go all in on the business
side and then there's nothing personal
and then you don't get a connection to
that person right you've gone like the
other way it's all personal uh and not
having enough of the copywriting side so
if I sign up for a copywriting I loved
your copy video and that's what I came
for then I'm gonna be disappointed not
disappointed but like um it's I'm not
getting what I'm so much more like
people will watch my channel or the
thing with entrepreneur videos that I
put out cuz that's most of my content
right i have i've liked the life with
eben wines and personal stuff that I
throw in there a couple times a week the
life with that one was once a week it's
not related to business at all just what
I'm doing and those are the least viewed
videos on my channel but I do them
because it's a it forms a connection
it's for the hardcore audience it makes
them closer to me they get a sense of
how I live or what i do when my
philosophies and that kind of stuff so
they're important to have I think if we
channel should have some personal
component to it the hardcore fan but
again the goal to go business got to put
stuff related to business so if the
challenge is how to take too long to
make it then how do you make that
simpler like how does it don't cover
five things cover one or don't do as
much editing you know if you walk in if
you talk about headlines maybe you walk
into a store and you see a headline or
you just have your newspaper or website
and you just show that and here's what's
wrong with the headline and how you
would fix it mhm mmm is that that could
be a quick video and then like you might
think of your normal step might have
five processes to what those could be
five mini videos that you can open
report at once at the beginning of the
month and then on it edit it and instead
of it being one video it's five that's
broken up in two minute videos instead
of
cuz your videos are they have meat to
them right there they're long aren't
they not very copy ones are I mean
depending on what they are but if they
have examples it can be like six two six
two nine minutes I mean that Portland
hot copy video was I think it was close
to eight or something so yeah so those
could be 42 minute videos each pilot
thing right oh you can chunk it down cuz
it's gone to the point where it's so
much work that you don't want to do it
and you doing other simple easy ones but
that's not really going to help you and
your goal is to build your business um
so I would really try to figure out a
spot to do once a week some kind of
copywriting video and then whether the
other ones are once a week twice a week
I think the important thing is that it's
consistent because if i look forward to
fantasy friday and then it's not there
it's a it's a letdown right so like
think about and maybe you pare down the
soup you know from five to three but you
make sure that you execute on those 30
before you explain it because if you can
grow your if you grow in copywriting
business you're making more money you
can hire an editor part time to help you
you can do five series you could do one
a day because now you're you're speaking
um maybe how your dog or two yeah cuz i
know she helped you ain't it tell me out
yeah so like so that if your skills are
in front of the camera and not out on
the editing your skills are the the the
coming with the concept what you're
going to be talking about being will
distill the knowledge and give a good
message and that's ideally longer term
we should be focused and then get people
to help you oh my you know i wouldn't go
into debt to hire video editor right
like you gotta make its the money to
then go spend some money to help you
yeah way to get the money is to post
stuff to help your business girl i agree
i like the idea to brainstorming ideas
that of ways i could do a couple any
video without like too much editing or
too much like writing two and then I'm
sure their ways I can do that and then
making them shorter and quicker because
like I have I
idea that I had to like always show
examples my copy which is good sometimes
then I don't always have to do that well
you any think about um you could break
it down where if you're talking about
here's a theory we're like here's here's
the why I could be a video then you can
do the how and that's a video and then
you can do an example that's the video
and so instead of stringing them all
together you can do them as three
different videos and linked to each
other okay stay tuned next week I'm
going to talk about how I do it next
week here's an example right and so you
get used to it and quick short
digestible videos um so not waiting so
long and it's not as big a burden on you
to be able to create them right okay I
like it so we've got some questions
coming in you want to handle some
questions sure as you know is writing
then hey Xena Xena is a hardcore fan I
something I'm struggling with is
thinking of a dream future for myself oh
I don't like my current life but I also
have no idea what I want my life to be
any tips for those without fantasies oh
my gosh I always get so surprised i
actually have a lot of people tell me
this they're like how do I fantasize I
don't know what to do I don't really
have a fantasy I'm like how do you not
have a famous easy I don't understand it
because I literally like have a little
Vinny fantasies all the time um and I
guess what I would say is just think
about the times that you know ah that
when you are happy and when you feel
good and um you know create that story
in your head of what you be doing when
you feel good and um and start there it
doesn't have to be a big fantasy it
doesn't have to be like you know you're
gonna be the king of your own city it
could be you know you know you just like
love the idea of you know dancing on the
ballroom floor with a date or something
right it could be something really small
and just start small and think about
things that make you feel good and um
and you know it'll grow from there baby
steps baby steps i would say 22 I you
know if you hate your life I don't think
you're gonna you're gonna figure out the
answer by just sitting at home right
like I think you gotta do stuff you got
floor try new things say yes to things
things that might scare you a little bit
you know take up salsa dancing learn
cool plays a guitar you know along that
path you'll discover yourself and you'll
find something that you fall in love
with that then you can create this
future with um it doesn't happen just by
staying at home you have to get out of
your current environment and you have to
get out of there you know people you
hang out with and do something different
I look at different meetups like this
doesn't have to cost you anything
doesn't have to cost much money at all
you can just go out and start to explore
I think for people finding their passion
who are lost that's what you have to do
it I know it sucks like it can when
you're not passionate about stuff it's
hard to want to get off the couch and go
do something because it's comfortable at
home um but that's how is my advice to
people who don't know what they want to
do yet I agree and I love the story you
always use Evan 11 Steve Jobs and how he
when he quit hit going to college he
started taking classes on Fox like that
to me is like the ultimate story I like
to use all the time because it was like
a random thing that he was interested in
right he was just interested in fonts
and so we took this class on fonts and
because it led to his passion for design
and you know making these amazing
commuters that had like compared fonts
on them and it just you know just follow
your path like little tiny little things
you're interested in like you wait don't
let your curiosity lead you you know
could be something really weird like
that yeah and the point with that source
you can't connect the dots looking
forward you can only connect the dots
looking back so like the things that you
try don't make sense and if you try to
make them make sense then then then
you'll stop you'll quit and with jobs he
had a you had this career lined out for
him great University but he quit to to
come back to school without getting
credit to sit in on on writing classes
and learn about fonts without knowing
why he did it just had this feeling like
I should I want to learn about
I'm just curious about it and then when
the first Mac came out his first
computer came out it was the only one
that have different fonts and that's
what separated the first mac computer
versus all the other computers is one of
beautiful finances is something that he
was interested in and had learned about
so now looking back it makes sense but
he didn't know he was going to start a
computer company right it's scary to
drop out to then learn about writing
silence right it's so um I mean I'm a
huge fan of that story too and the thing
i guess i would encourage you to is do a
lot of small starts uh you know I want
rock climbing and I hated it you know
like the harness is tight and in my
crotch and I'm afraid of heights and I
still said yes like I'm I'll try a lot
of things once and that should be your
approach I find if you don't know what
you want to do try bunch of stuff and
just think it is only once I got to do
it once it doesn't work I don't like it
I'm gonna go do something else I did
salsa dancing and I fell in love with it
instantly and on paper I'm too tall and
I don't speak Spanish and I take big
steps and I didn't have the musicality
and NN and and and then all these
reasons why i would never be great at
salsa and if i just paid attention to
that i would have never gotten started
in it but i've been dancing now for over
10 years investor in a business
instructor DJ met my wife threw huge
passion in my life just by dropping on a
salsa class so you never know when it's
gonna show up um lovely i like to add
that i love the vulnerability jen showed
in the harvest day of my life video oh
that's awesome i think you have been for
showing that and and showing my channel
off that was pretty awesome that was
really awesome yours your celebrity now
my cry clearly see you can see the
passion dripping off your face along
with the tears go you all right that's
amazing thank you somebody else in right
in will smile alright hey that
everybody's just ranting and raving
about Jen here okay
Raymond any advice for someone who just
finished high school I wants to be an
entrepreneur where do I start what do I
do wow I think it's one question for you
Evan I think you what we were talking
about follow your dreams right follow
your passions it could be something
small right because you can't you can't
start a business just to make money it's
not gonna work yeah I would probably do
two things i would i would start
something on the side whatever i was
interested in and then i would also go
to i would also find it on to further i
respect and go work for them and learn
about an industry and understand how
business works and see if that's
something that I wanted to do more of or
not um I had a bunch of small ventures
when I started from selling baseball
cards to trying to create a software
company to then creating a software
company um yeah so i would i would try
to learn from someone who's done it that
was probably one of the biggest mistakes
that I made was I just I didn't learn
and I almost failed cuz I thought I
could figure it all out myself um an
insert on the side yeah starting aside
from her what you also know if you
really like it cuz wait for once you're
working on side you like if you really
love it you'll get up early in the
morning and work at night you know
instead of watching TV because you know
you love it I love it Zeno's writing
back thanks for answering my question
Joan and Edmond I'm gonna try to take
baby steps and try new things I love it
man that's good pushing forward Floyd
what is your opinion on selling out do
you think it's viable long-term to
tailor your content to your audience or
should you aim to establish your own
market that's a tough one I think you
got to find a sweet spot in between you
got to find that thing where you're
giving value to other people if you're
just doing it for your own indulgence
and nobody cares about it it's not going
to resonate but if you're doing
something you stand for something and
and you're providing value to the people
through what you stand for then you know
then you've got a business you seen I'm
a musician facing a dilemma because
financials getting harder sustained a
business making selling out more thank
you or what what do you say more
appealing more appealing so he's like
struggling for money so selling out
seeing
killing you now um no I'm a big training
in making stuff selfishly for you and
then sharing it with the world uh I feel
like it has more heart to do it um you
know my interests a series of my top 10
cities even the music series that I just
launched now I mean it for me like I
felt like this was missing nobody's done
it I didn't want to do it but I would
needed it and so since nobody else has
created I'm gonna I'm gonna create it I
wish somebody else came up with an
espresso so i could just consume it i
just want to customer want to make it i
don't want to do the list want to be i
won the top 10 series I feel like most
people have a terrible environment that
doesn't support with them and build them
up and so I wanted to stretch myself and
my thinking and hanging up with Richard
Branson and Donald Trump and Oprah
Winfrey and their views and have
somebody every day and again nobody had
made that so I then had to hire team and
make it um and so I would one look at
making music that that you love that is
an expression of yourself that you want
to share and an easy way I don't know if
you consider the selling out or not is I
would be looking at how can i leverage
songs that already exist and put my spin
on it so a lot of the a lot of the
artists get started by covering other
songs right you cover other artists but
you put it in your own your own style
right it shows off your abilities you
take frozen let it go when you make it
like a hard rock or something right and
it always attracts attention and it's a
great way to get exposed your unique
songs and the songs that you've written
that nobody's heard of yet um a big
challenge I find with any artist is you
need to beat on your craft like you may
not be good enough yet and your talent
should be obvious and that comes by
practicing and practice this inner
practicing and practicing and and you'll
produce a lot of stuff that isn't up to
standard yet but it'll get better every
time you do
it were I would worry Jen did we talk
about that what talk about which way
Eminem when mm called in to radio show
that I talked about the no no wasn't
right story okay bolsas floyd is here
musician is a great story Wow Eminem
likes to crank call radio shows and he
had LL Cool J was one of his earliest
like I look up to LL Cool J I want to be
like him and so LOL couch was on a radio
show an eminem called in under some fake
name like john from miami or something
and said hey hey LL Cool J I want to
wrap some songs for you and I want you
to tell me what songs they are he's like
okay I'm up for that game so he starts
rapping it and he picks up the songs and
then while he's rapping you know after
LL Cool J and the radio host boasting
hey you're really good like you got some
serious talent you should be you should
get you should like really trying to
promote yourself and try to build a
career and then he sang his his famous
on here apt lose yourself and god you're
like um but the point is like this was a
nobody who called in right uh nobody but
he had mmm level talent and it was
immediately recognized so can people
recognize your talent right and if they
can't then what do you have to do to
improve your talent its practice and
practice and practice practice so number
one keep put in the effort and the
hustle on the hard work and get better
what you're doing and to discover
yourself and discover your angle and
then to look at how you can bring your
own twist to popular songs as a way to
promote the unique stuff that you're
given as well that's my advice I love it
that's my advice um what else we have
here buh buh buh buh bah Randy I want to
document myself battling fears my own
one and strangers do I start off with
people I know out there what do you
think advise her Randy so he wants to
document himself his fears uh his own
and strangers he wants a document
himself and other people
modeling fears you start off with people
he knows or just put himself out there
it's what he's asking whoo that sounds
kind of interesting I think both I don't
know that's just my instinctive answer i
don't know why i like it i would say i
would say whatever gets you started you
know like honestly the biggest thing
that holds people back is not starting
you have this idea and then you're
scared of how people might judge you and
you're scared of how you judge yourself
or you wake up one morning with a great
idea and then the next when you wake up
and you look as I can't do that that's
way too I was crazy to think that so I
think both are interesting I think
telling your story about fear and how
you've overcome it and what you're doing
and your ups and downs and if it's
working or not ah that's great I think
if you interview other people and they
talk about their fears and how they've
overcome them that's great you know I
have a story about fear that I'm have to
do an interview with you and share and
get you started on your path um whatever
ever you got to start the key is to
start not expect perfection and just
keep going and getting better every time
so whatever helps you get started faster
that's what I would go with I agree a
hundred percent I love it in Floyd
musician saying thanks have an agenda is
great advice love it Floyd I want to
hear your cover song of some insanely
popular track with your spin on it hit
me up I'm going to play it I want to
comment it I want to share it um cool
we're a little bit over the time um lots
of questions Jen I love the progress
awesome thank you so much everybody's
okay I love it one copy video crew week
when happened one person ok ok we're
going to be tracking and for people
watching it's in the description but
tell them where they can find out about
your channel uh yeah my channel is video
so much on YouTube and it's just under
the title much um that's that's what it
is it's under video so much though all
right you guys can all watch your
channel and help hold her accountable I
love them I love that
okay thank you jen thank you for money
for watching and I will see you soon bye
you